Seatbelts and airbags in cars save passengers
lives.
Parachutes save people who, for a variety
of reasons, exit a plane in mid-flight.
So why aren’t parachutes provided to passengers
on commercial airline flights, in case of
emergencies?
Because they almost certainly would not save
anyone’s life.
Parachuting Basics
When your average daredevil skydives for fun,
the plane is typically travelling at between
80 and 110 mph when the skydiver jumps.
Tandem and accelerated free fall (AFF) jumps
occur between 10,000 and 13,000 feet, while
static jumps can be as low as 3,500 feet.
Student divers choosing the easiest, tandem
jump, where the newbie is physically and securely
attached to an experienced instructor, are
still required to undergo “a half hour of
basic ground instruction.”
Braver neophytes who wish to fly untethered
will have to endure:
Four to five hours of intense ground instruction,
including learning body flight maneuvers and
hand signals that instructors use to coach
the student as they fly alongside.
For an AFF jump, although not harnessed together,
freshman flyers are accompanied by two instructors
who “hold onto the student’s harness until”
it’s deployed.
Those who choose a static line jump also have
to take four + hours of training prior to
the jump, although the parachute is deployed
as the rookie flyer leaves the aircraft.
When skydivers leave a plane, they do it alone
or in small groups.
When successive groups will be jumping, they
try to keep separated by anywhere between
500 and 1500 feet; this is often accomplished
by waiting until the preceding group is “back
under the tail to 45 degrees behind the airplane”
or several seconds in between groups.
Experienced skydivers can make even riskier
jumps, although when descents begin at higher
than 15,000 feet, “the risk of hypoxia and
being significantly affected by altitude”
increases dramatically and divers are less
able “to make effective safe decisions at
critical times.”
Therefore, divers who jump from 15,000 feet
or higher carry supplemental oxygen.
Further, each parachute weighs around 40 pounds
and the equipment is expensive.
To be fully outfitted with “rig, main, reserve,
ADD, altimeter, jumpsuit, helmet [and] goggles”
can run between $5,900 and $9,000.
Commercial Airplane Basics
Perhaps the most popular commercial jetliner
is the Boeing 737 family.
Its 737-800 can carry nearly 200 people (including
the crew).
Although speeds can vary slightly, the 737-800
travels at approximately 600 mph when at its
cruising altitude of 35,000 feet.
Cruising altitudes are assigned by air traffic
controllers and are usually up to 39,000 feet,
except for longer flights that may fly higher.
Individual Parachutes Won’t Improve Passenger
Safety
Doing the math . . .
Passenger Training
Since four hours of training just to board
a plane is unrealistic, passengers would have
to read and execute detailed skydiving instructions
including how to properly strap the chute
on in order to benefit from the parachute.
Not everyone is good at following detailed,
technical instructions even when time and
stress aren’t a factor.
In a situation where the plane is going down
and one has only a moment to get the parachute
properly strapped on (likely while keeping
an oxygen mask firmly attached and perhaps
also needing to keep the seat belt on to keep
from being thrown about in the cabin), it’s
unlikely most would be able to even get this
far.
Every Man for Himself
Unless passengers wanted to fly suited up
and tethered for a static jump, parachuting
from a commercial airplane will be an AFF
jump; however, unlike the conditions that
students get – training and trained instructors
to assist, commercial passengers will just
have to learn as they go.
In addition, they will have to keep calm and
proceed in an orderly fashion, which will
require most to patiently wait their turn
to exit.
This is not likely to happen.
Parachuting Equipment is Bulky
Adding just parachutes (not counting helmets,
altimeters, etc.) for each passenger would
add another 8,000 pounds or so to the flight’s
weight.
In addition, that equipment would take up
space, that is already at a premium.
Parachuting Only Makes Sense if Something
Happens in Mid-Flight
The only feasible time for people to jump
from the plane is while it’s cruising.
However, most fatal airline accidents occur
on airplanes during takeoff and landing.
Consider that between 2003 and 2012, only
9% of all fatal accidents on commercial flights,
seven total, occurred while the plane was
cruising; moreover, at least one of those
accidents happened as a result of wind shear
or thunderstorm.
This is a situation where parachuting is extremely
dangerous even if you’re an expert.
So even if parachuting were feasible from
a jetliner, the conditions in which parachutes
could theoretically save lives are almost
never apparent in fatal commercial accidents.
But even if they were, it still wouldn’t
be a good idea.
Jetliners Cruise Very High and Very Fast
At 35,000 feet (three times higher than a
typical jump) every passenger would need high
altitude equipment (HALO) that includes an
oxygen tank, mask and regulator, flight suit,
ballistic helmet and altimeter just to manage
the thin air.
Or they could just pass out from hypoxia and
wake up later, hopefully when the parachute
automatically deployed at under 15,000-20,000
feet.
Of course, none of this would matter since
the plane is moving so fast (600 mph), and
it is so large, that many passengers would
almost certainly smash into it and suffer
debilitating if not fatal injuries.
Whole Plane Parachutes May Save Lives
There is hope, however.
Over the past few years, many small planes
have been equipped with whole-plane parachutes
that slow the craft’s descent.
As of late 2013, the largest planes equipped
with these safety devices carry five people,
but plans are in the works for putting them
on larger crafts.
As one manufacturer said, “There is no doubt
that big commercial airlines of the future
will be equipped with some kind of parachute
recovery system.”